[Music]
guys of all the bright lights and big
stages of eSports few could compete with
the prestige and the raw unadulterated
hype of CS goes premier level of
competition
there's just something magical about a
major
[Music]
majors create champions they bring our
scene together and they birth moments
that become itched in the collective
memory of counter-strike is it any
wonder then that we finally decided to
give you what we think are the top ten
csgo major kills of all time now before
we get into this video proper just a
couple quick notes for a play to be
considered for this list has to include
at least one direct kill which means
unfortunately no dojo grenade for
example the plays have to have a lasting
place in csgo history they have to have
mattered at the time in the game they
happened in and yeah they got to be sick
as hell
now without criteria out of the way
let's get into it with the top 10 csgo
major kills of all times kicking off our
list is this play from Fryeburg at ESL
one cologne 2014's grand final ninjas in
pyjamas had just come back from an 11-4
deficit against fnatic and after trading
kills Freiburg was pinched between two
terrorists in an actor plant scenario
now Freiburg is gonna be walkin around
that promise down and Firebug looking
for a way to equalize the situation he's
gonna be walking up spots pronax here in
the corner takes him down turns around
for the 180 still 15 I mean really
walking in there and you already saw he
knew exactly where the second man would
be where foster would be holding from
trying to control the spray doesn't 180
but keeps his coal after seeing this
play I dare you to deny the existence of
nip magic coming in at number 9 is a
North American fan favorite from MLG
Columbus 2016 during Team Liquid
semi-final against luminosity gaming
Kiko found himself outnumbered
four-to-one with the bomb still left to
diffuse but in true he co fashioned the
counter-strike veteran disposed of the
Brazilians one by one with just enough
time left to clutch at the round now
again as we see so many times before is
down to hiko but against four is it
really possible you do have a few
players quite tagged up here from
luminosity say he Co definitely not
going down without a fight
oh well there's the first part right
here
it's a double there's still two players
left they got no help on them thirteen
and three hiko looping around the site
now there's still time it's all my
goodness how did he do this
Iko is the clutch gods all countess
right surely I have no words for that
but I was just perfectly there getting
those two first arrow forklift in them
when simple gets out of his chair to
grab your hand you know you've done
something good our number eight entry
comes courtesy of olofmeister and no
it's not the Olaf boost but we'll get to
that a little later
now for this play Olaf found himself on
the wrong end of a 1v4 against natus
Vincere at ESL one Katowice 2015 with
only a tec-9 in hand the legendary Swede
sent a message to the world
never underestimate him in any
circumstance running and gunning takes
down JW and all of my stats Hank 9 and
armour it's really really good
combination but unless they fight him
one of the time oh my god are they will
pronax helping out with that kill and
Guardian going down and it's now a
triple kill fall off my he's got plenty
of help to do this as well soos is very
low seized
although oh my god he gets another kill
in now clocks running out seven seconds
all of my Stucky for the kill 5 secs he
goes for it and it's gonna be the round
done and fnatic steel it all off Meister
steals it insane beginning coming out
for Olaf we were just discussing you
know Navi can be that emotional side if
something gets them on tilt what could
possibly make you tilt more than all of
my standing in ace of the first round of
the game that seems it seems
unbelievable coming in at number 7 is
this play from snacks a TMS one Katowice
2014
taking on ninjas and pajamas in the
grand finals snack showed off the
lurking and trigger discipline that
we've all come to know and love and
showed n IP the real ninjas
puts necks is walking around he waited
and then he finished up the job
you just have to wonder when was he
going to pull the trigger and when he
did it was quite magnificent and the
crowd is on his feet to just claim this
play was just very very close called
blooded from smack and he just took the
maximum out of this iteration the number
six play on our list sees Freiburg live
up to his moniker as the king of banana
at ESL one cologne 2014 against fnatic
in the grand final ninjas in pyjamas
were down 5-1 in the early rounds of the
deciding map with the bomb headed to a
Freiburg was tasked with doing what he
could at banana and the King delivered
single-handedly taking the site and
cleaning up the round with an ace
Freiburg does return picks off pronax
he's still here though and he's going
for more - big frags that third man is
here Harbor and Freiburg has to back off
single-handedly all three frags
but the bomb is on the other side yeah
but that could be all right if an icicle
making a huge rotation Freiburg already
has to just stay alive and it's gonna be
great
Paul he picks up a quad kill he could do
even better than staying alive he gets
the kill now from the depths 500 just
inching his way forward here he wants
that ace and that would be absolutely
brutal phonetic retreat erupt and fry
becomes in his praise
Freiburg misses
[Applause]
it's financing what up flea that this
could be a turning point live that has
got to be shattering for fnatic and they
bounce back from being manhandled by
Freiburg and the master of banana
certainly is here only him walking
forward and getting all three frags to
open up that site but at the halfway
point in our list is a double kill that
is just so quintessentially simple at
ESL one cologne 2016 semi final simple
made history with one of the craziest
double kills ever be witnessed at a
major you can chalk it up to luck you
can chalk it up to skill or a bit of
both but you can't deny this cemented
spot as one of the best players in the
world coming in at number four is kenny
ass at ESL one cologne 2015 now Kenny is
an offer known for dunking on his
opponents in a matter the stakes and
this quarterfinal match against Navi was
no different okay maybe this one's a
little different because the man on the
other side of the server was none other
than Guardian the other contender for
greatest offer in the world at the time
after trading shot after shot at the a
bomb site Kenny did the unthinkable is
he gonna try and go huge it Kenny is off
site
make it three nothing oh I didn't Lord
that was putting automatic NES picking
up so many kills in that round taking
the number three spot on our list is one
of the most controversial plays ever to
happen in csgo history let alone at a
major dreamhack winter 2014 was the
birthplace of the now infamous Olaf
boost and with two quick kills off of
this game breaking tactic fnatic mounted
one of the most incredible comebacks
we've ever seen all of my still waiting
the patience game coming again spot them
coming out of squeak doors while he's
here he sees them now they're straight
headshot they have no idea Smith's
looking confused and dazed and it's
gonna be a
you've gotta be kidding me take the
humorous world people do a fine job in a
but it is the returns an empty they pick
up the booze bollocks
he was just he was just building up the
suspense olofmeister he actually saw
those guys go by but he knew that he
could do more damage if he let them go
all the way down to squeak but this he
had no idea the end is near it's five on
three and fnatic have summoned an
unbelievable comeback they make that way
to the semis of another major tournament
[Applause]
the controversy and the backlash were
almost instant following the game
tournament officials wanted overpass to
be replayed but fnatic declined and
forfeited the rest of the major
so despite technically losing this was
just one of the many defining plays of
Olaf Meister's illustrious career this
list would just not be complete without
cold zeroes jumping off which is why it
comes in second on our list at MLG
Columbus 2016 Team Liquid were
desperately trying to close out Mirage
in their semi-final series against
luminosity but that's when we witnessed
some unthinkable scenes at the B
apartments and well you know the rest
comes once again the first base is it
trainees gonna hit the ground there's
cold something I'm never gonna see ever
again
ridiculous that's the most ridiculous
thing I've ever seen there's only one
kill that best to find fanatics legacy
in csgo that's right taking first place
on our list of major kills is the famous
firing squad from ESL one cologne 2015
fnatic were up two rounds in overtime
against team envyus during the grand
final with a substantial economic lead
now snipers have battled from opposite
ends of dust - since the Maps creation
but apex was not prepared for what
awaited him on the other side of mid
doors this time cross the middle it's
gonna be a challenge and not in this
lifetime he is destroyed well when
they're lining up like that you know
you're in trouble and look at what apex
sees here well it was later removed this
play would lead to the first kill
inspired graffiti to ever grace dust to
making it not only one of the most
iconic moments from the fnatic era but
one of the first to be immortalized in
counterstrikes history well guys that
was our list now whether you loved it or
you hated it let us know in the comments
below and hey I know a lot of these
plays were historical and if you're
looking for something more current well
we do have a best of the 2019 ketamine
se major video waiting for you elsewhere
on our channel check that out and I'll
see you next week thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button